the powerful storm that slamming Texas
is now blamed for at least two deaths
Houston was inundated with more than
nine inches of rain yesterday that
breaks the single day record set in 1979
by more than two inches many communities
devastated by hurricane Harvey's
floodwaters just two years ago find
themselves underwater again Houston Fire
officials say they responded to nearly
two thousand emergency incidents video
captured this incredible F wine
evacuation through flood waters in
Humble Texas CBS affiliate KHOU says
more than 50 horses were rescued by Good
Samaritans Texas governor Greg Abbott
issued disaster declarations in 13
counties including chamber chambers
County that's east of Houston and that's
where Mireya Villarreal is talking to
residents in hard-hit Winnie Maria how
are people they're describing the storm
well good morning guys you know the
people that we're talking to in Winnie
say they were hit even harder than
Harvey just a few years ago now the
flood waters in town they are tapering
off as we speak but officials say
they've got 20 inches of rain in just
four hours making it hard for residents
like this right here to keep up with all
that water downtown Winnie was a sea of
impassable roads littered with floating
debris and abandoned cars Thursday a
view from above drives the point home a
city under water more than 300 people
had to be rescued by military trucks and
boats here
riding along with Chambers County
Sheriff Brian Hawthorn we saw the
devastation firsthand a lot of these
homes were flooded out during Hurricane
Harvey and some of the owners just got
back in two years later but the severity
of these latest floods may mean the stay
is temporary it takes a lot of time to
reveal the first time
12 hours it's back to Ground Zero gene
LeBlanc's house was among the estimated
800 homes and businesses affected by the
storm now he and his son Adam fear all
their progress since Harvey has been
washed away a lot of roads are now
starting to open up as the water start
to recede so the flash flooding looks
like it might be over right now for this
area but you can tell that there's a lot
of water still in people's front yards
officials say it could be two to three
days before all of this starts to recede
and the sheriff tells me it could be
months before any in people in these you
know neighborhoods actually feel like
there's some normalcy how the
devastation seen and the tear in that
young man's face Maria thank you